what month is it right now cuz if you
like January from I've said it is 2020
February is the new January anyhow let's
review the boy - or Brahms and what's -
it
[Music]
so Brahms the boy - as the title
suggests is the sequel to the boy and
the boy - it follows a family Katie
Holmes plays the mom there was a
burglary and then she's traumatized the
kids traumatize the kid doesn't speak
anymore because he's traumatized so they
go to get away from it all not to Kokomo
but to this really creepy house why not
actually pretty nice house next to the
creepy house and the kid digs up a doll
and the doll's name Brahms and Brahms is
telling them to do some crazy stuff and
be more creepy okay so what I liked
about this movie is when this movie
treated itself like a psychological
thriller it was like what's going on
with the doll is the doll alive is it
all not alliance also the parental
element that was actually the best part
of the movie was the parental element
the kids traumatized he doesn't speak
but he does talk to the dolls it was
like do we keep the doll around he seems
to that seems to be bringing him out of
his shell just trying to roll with it
she's like okay and then it just starts
irritating her and that creates conflict
between her and her son like that was
fine because if I was apparently what
would I do I start placing myself in
there and I have no idea
probably just ah Brahms ran away by ran
away I mean I burned him but that
doesn't save the movie for me really
boring
the movies just a drag it moves at a
snail's pace because it thinks the
intrigue is enough for you this movie
never gets you there the whole time
you're just like right things still
aren't happening
and it just falls into its own cliches
of being a cliche horror film not even
horror film boring ghost ish movie with
a haunted doll I mean folks people
friends I'm not just talking about jump
scares like jump scares yes but third
jump scares where there are no jump
scares just think where Katie Holmes is
in this dark hallway which you know
alright ghost movie haunted movie creepy
doll dark hallways gonna happen she's
walking through it and then it does that
horror movie sound you know the one but
usually accompanied by something in this
movie she's just like creepy staff
flashlight in my doesn't mind me my
flashlight she's like oh what is this oh
you're not even reacting so it's not
like everything ran past you or ran past
the screen so we could see it it's just
like it's a sound that happened that
feels like they were editing the movie
they were like alright if the audience
isn't asleep by now they're about to be
wait a minute are we in post-production
or are we in post-production let's just
do the horror movies down you know the
one yeah whatever that is we'll just
have that sound happen that should wake
some people up get some adrenaline
spikes be limbic response doesn't matter
that's right the creative process does
not stop and post funny enough the
creative process didn't start for this
movie in the first place I mean there
are sequels out there that even if they
don't stick the landing you can tell
there was some form of inspiration there
it's like take glass for example I
wasn't crazy about glass but some people
were but that's kind of my point it
works for some people not so much for
others but it worked for some people
because there was the feeling that M
night Shyamalan tried he tried to do
something big with the movie actually
gave an effort then there are movies
like sinister - or Brahms the boy -
where you just get the feeling the
studio called upon to have a sequel
inspiration or not you're not inspired
doesn't matter just vomit out a script
it'll work do you need to watch the
first movie the boy to enjoy the boy -
well that's the thing I never actually
I've never seen the boy
I didn't there's just one of those
movies I haven't seen I know about the
ending of the boy in the same capacity
if you haven't seen the sixth sense you
probably know about the ending of the
sixth sense I've seen YouTube videos
about the ending of the boy I've heard
from people who have seen the boy about
the boy so I know what happens I know
the reveal at the end of the boy what I
know this movie seems to directly
contradict it or at least conflict with
it I just don't know how the boy and
Brahms the boy two can coexist in the
same universe it just seemed like
opposing forces and there was a part of
me that was like maybe I should watch
the boy before I watch the boy - and I'm
totally down for watching the boy
because the ending actually does sound
pretty cool I mean in concept anyway I
don't know how the execution is but
watching it because I want to watch it
that's good that that's a good
motivation that's a good reason to watch
a movie watching the boy to brush up for
Brahms the boy - it's not a good enough
reason I'm sorry it's not enough for me
and I'm reminded of the philosophy of
the great castor Troy [ __ ] its Brahms
the boy - we'll be fine to answer the
question do you need to see the boy to
enjoy the boy - no you need to be in a
coma to enjoy this movie because whether
or not it seems to conflict - the first
one doesn't it doesn't matter the movies
still boring but when this movie
straighten itself like a psychological
thriller I was kind of going along with
it but I'm still not gonna remember this
in t-minus one day yeah I've already
forgot our you're not gonna see Brahms -
boy - funny enough I've been playing
Final Fantasy 7 I was like okay the
remake suppose it's gonna be through
midgar's so I'm gonna play the original
through Midgar and now I'm at the end I
just couldn't put it down so I'm gonna
level up my materia so what video game
were you hooked on right now best
question I can ask cuz no question
involving this movie is a good question
well whatever it is comment below let me
know and as always if you like what you
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you
[Music]